[Music]
this morning on a special edition of the
dish we introduced you to Bryant Terry
he's a James Beard award-winning chef
educator author and activist but these
days you won't find him in a restaurant
instead he's the chef and residents at a
San Francisco Museum where he celebrates
the intersection of food and culture
while encouraging us all to create a
more equitable and sustainable food
system I would argue that this is the
recipe that's the foundation of my new
books okay it's a citrus and garlic herb
braised fennel not many people get
excited about fennel not like chef
Bryant Terry have you had cooked fennel
I'm sure I've had it I do know that in
his new cookbook vegetable kingdom his
fit to date the James Beard Award winner
presents recipes focused on some 30
vegetables and you smell the anise like
yes hoping to once again lure readers to
the bounty of a plant-based diet my
personal transformation when I was in
high school it was a hip-hop song Boogie
Down Productions rap beef by ke rs1 you
mind if I keep the lyrics yeah go for it
okay
so goes like this beef what a relief
when will this poisonous product cease
[Music]
21 different drugs are pumped into the
cow and one big lump it gets much more
graphic so I'm gonna stop chef Terry is
unapologetically vegan what about those
folks out there who are daunted by the
idea of veganism I tell people just ease
into it
meatless Mondays vegan before 6:00 try
maybe going one or two meals without me
you know I think this idea that you're
gonna be missing something could be
counterbalanced by really exploring all
the interesting diverse vegetables like
fennel fennel aside is day job as the
inaugural chef in residence with the
Museum of African Diaspora I think that
this museum is a symbol it's a beacon
it's it's a place where I think our
people can find refuge I'm so blessed
that they let me curate this in 2015 he
was charged with expanding the
conversation on African American food in
a city with a rapidly declining black
population that's what is so special
about this museum to me is that it
connects all the people of African
descent throughout the globe
it's an idea close to home for a father
of two who says he wrote his book for
his daughters when people think about
plant-based eating so often we imagine
it as these practices of upper middle
class white suburban Heights right and I
think it's important for me to recognize
that my my introduction to these ideas
came from black people recipes inspired
by traditional soul food where greens
and legumes were the stars so this is a
roasted potato and cabbage dish with the
carrot puree at the bottom and we
drizzle a little ginger habanero sauce
on top
the genesis of his professional culinary
education came while earning his
graduate degree in history and weiu
I was taking the subway and I see this
group of young people children at seven
o'clock in the morning eating chips
candy bars drinking sodas and it just
hit me that you know these young people
were eating but there
empty calories you know this wasn't real
food it was then he started be healthy
which helped kids make smarter choices
about food that led him to the chef's
training program at the natural gourmet
Institute his inspiration behind it all
invited to speak at the Museum
earlier this month I would say Ericka
Huggins is one of my primary influences
for wanting to start an organization
that taught children about food Ericka
Huggins organized community programs as
a member of the Black Panther Party that
revolutionary political organization
founded in 1966 by Bobby Seale and Huey
P Newton they were responding to police
violence against black citizens right
across the bridge in Oakland California
the most important work that they were
doing which was largely done by women
they were doing everything like having
ambulance services to take people to the
hospital they had free clinics they had
grocery giveaways where they were giving
away thousands of pounds of groceries to
low-income residents of the Bay Area and
they had a program called the free
breakfast for children program whose aim
was feeding young people a hot
nourishing breakfast every single
morning real food like the kind from his
grandfather's backyard in Mississippi
which closely resembles today's farmers
markets and CSAs communities really
shared neighbors shared with one another
my grandfather would be like I'm gonna
give you a bag of walnuts you give me
some of those pears he had so much that
he would give it away to all his
children he would take the surplus to
church it was a thriving local food
system and what saddens me is when I go
back there and it's just a shell of
itself it's a nationwide problem
according to the USDA 14 million
households in America don't have access
to affordable and nutritious food which
can add to dangerously high rates of
hypertension heart disease type 2
diabetes and certain cancers there was a
study about this neighborhood West
Oakland California in 2008 and they
found that there were 53 corner stores
and liquor stores in this community and
not one single supermarket not one
single supermarket and so I wonder you
know
what if we shifted that what if we went
back to that thriving local food system
how would that impact the public health
in their community
the Memphis native has partnered with
allies like his mentor Alice Waters the
Berkeley food activists and owner of the
legendary Chez Panisse but ultimately he
is motivating communities to lead the
charge themselves this food movement has
this exploded a lot of people are
thinking about creative ways of kind of
regaining our food system taking it back
from the multinational corporations
having local seasonal sustainable food
systems and you've become a food justice
advocate advocate activist it depends on
who you ask
we have a history and legacy of eating
you know healthful food but because of
our fast food culture so many of us have
forgotten about that it's almost like
this cultural amnesia for Terry it's
really about feeding the mind body and
soul of all people I want people to
understand the diversity and complexity
of our cuisine and not just pigeonhole
it I'm helping people remember that
these are our legacies these are our
histories and it's really a matter of
kind of looking back as we move forward
and and Terry really has had an impact I
mean there has worked with Alice Waters
from Chez Panisse as I mentioned he
talked about that West Oakland
neighborhood that didn't have a
supermarket well they have one now it's
really interesting to see how motivating
people to take charge can make a
difference good start